[Music]
what would it mean to you to make it to
the finals they'll mean a lot to me and
I know it's one of you guys who dream
and now it's one of my dreams so I
really want to get an LBO good memory
one pair will dance their way to
Mirrorball glory on Sunday season finale
of Dancing with the Stars jr. I am so
happy that we made it this far I never
thought that we would we need to kill it
what is your goal in this competition
well what type of question is that I
need to get the Mirrorball of course and
ET is taking a look at finalists Ariana
Greenblatt's miles Brown Mackenzie
Ziggler and Skyy Browns favorite
memories from the season
[Music]
like
say something to all the girls out there
now you can do anything just have fun be
brave and do it because you love it
don't let anybody stop you that message
that you gave to all the little girls
out there you grabbed that microphone
and you said how important it is to be a
strong young lady why did you want to
say that because Lorna she's brave she
loves the ocean and she just does it so
especially if they want to do something
or like just somebody says you can't do
it just do it just do it the most
inspiring is there ever a pop star or a
celebrity maybe that you like imagine
yourself being and being like you know
I'm gonna go out there and channel this
person definitely I mean there's - okay
he's - Beyonce oh but she just
absolutely works the self my inspiration
for the first dance the cha-cha the the
very beginning of the dance I walk and I
do this
[Applause]
fiancee is it be Beyonce and then the
second one will probably have a big
party food cardi B oh no matter what
what's the best thing about doing the
show so far I get to learn their styles
and dance and the style that I'm like
really wanted to learn plus I you know I
haven't danced it a little bit so I
wanna you know get back to dancing
yep's having fun and I came to see my
friends and stuff so yeah I think making
new friendships and also learning how to
dance like ballroom because I've always
wanted to learn but like I've never been
really determined to do it so now that I
got to do it and compete with it and do
it with someone that's very good at
ballroom and have a really good teacher
it's like so I mean you are a serious
rock star in the ballroom where does
that confidence come from my family my
family's just so supportive and they're
so nice and I really do have the best
family ever they're always just like
girl you look amazing
lay it on the stage vu and that really
helps me in this thing like this one
good one
[Music]